we are at a tipping point everything
that is exceptional everything that's
great about this country the greatest
country God gave man our United States
of America I tell you tonight is in
jeopardy in 118 days guess what you're
the ultimate jury and the very way of
life that we cherish in many ways is at
stake I'll give a long explanation
everything that we value and cherish
like capitalism Liberty freedom the
Constitution the rule of law hangs in
the balance because the most extreme
radical socialist Democrats are planning
and they're saying it to fundamentally
transform and change America they want
to dismantle capitalism they want to
abolish the police that would eliminate
all law and order and safety and
security and the very corrupt the very
frail Joe Biden is controlled by these
radicals he is weak he is often confused
he's easily manipulated and now he's
showing his true colors and he will say
and he will do anything he is told to do
and say to win at all costs breaking
tonight look at this the Biden Sanders
socialist unity task force well they
just released well basically the
platform of Bernie Sanders and they're
proposing the DNC platform and it reads
like well a radical socialist wish list
and as President Biden he would grant
one citizenship to 11 million illegal
immigrants he would turn the entire
country into the United sanctuary States
of America he would block ice from
deporting even criminals in jail and
Biden would redistribute your money
because of something we call
environmental justice and of course the
insane green new deal that he supports
and get this Biden's task force actually
copied Bernie Sanders platform in
multiple sections word-for-word so in
other words Biden also calls for
universal health care through a public
option get this you would eliminate cash
bail for prisoners that's working so
well in New York right rob a bank
get out robbed another get out robbed
another anarchist get out go back to the
anarchy right Joe
doing great in New York that is madness
that is insanity that does not protect
the people in America's towns and cities
and today during an interview with the
far-left website now this news Joe Biden
even stated the police ready for this
have become the enemy and Biden also
said he's absolutely on board with
defunding the police listen closely
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement they don't need that the
last thing you need is an up-armored
hmmwv coming into a neighborhood just
like the military invading they don't
know anybody to become the enemy they're
supposed to protecting these people so
my generic point is that we agree that
we can redirect some of the funding yes
absolutely one of the things that we
also need to be doing is fundamentally
changing the way and i'ma pushing it for
years
changing the way we deal with our prison
system remember it was only a month ago
Biden rejected calls to defund the
police he did it in an op-ed and it took
just one month for Biden a cave to the
radicals in his party if he even wrote
or let alone remembers the topic of his
own op-ed instead of moving to the
center for the general election he is
now regurgitating the hard left talking
points from the extreme socialists who
are among his top advisors like Bernie
Sanders and Acacio Cortes need more
evidence because today Biden also vowed
to rewrite our economy just like he said
over the weekend he would transform
America whatever that means take a look
we're gonna have a breathtaking
opportunity to create good-paying union
jobs deliver the promise of America to
Americans who've been denied it for much
too long to rewrite our economy so the
prosperity flows not just the CEOs but
the workers who actually build the
country rewrite the economy socialist
utopia transform America police of the
enemy defund the police let me translate
this for you Biden is talking about
socialism just like Bernie just like
Elizabeth Warren probably even worse and
just like congresswoman Acacio Cortez
now we know what he meant when he said
to transform
America that will be raising your taxes
that will be confiscation of wealth that
will be control of the means of
production wherever possible and the
elimination of the lifeblood of the
world economy oil and gas and this is
now the mission of the democratic
extreme socialist party this is what
they want this is what they're saying
they're going to do this now that is the
proposal the Biden Bernie unity
socialist task force and Biden who
rarely leaves his own house seemingly
always in a state of confusion well he's
a perfect candidate for these radicals
cuz they will control him obviously
Biden couldn't even remember what he was
talking about while even apparently
reading from the teleprompter oh just
taking me too long okay go look at this
I believe this every fiber might be
we're posed I what I proposed is is it
can be done I think we're in a position
to to really make it happen and my team
in your team already working closely
together and liked to light up the path
forward here critical laws like the
proact to strengthen collective
bargaining i'm politics like prevailing
and look I guess I'm getting I'm taking
too much time but I propose that I
propose and this is taking too long
we'll have to keep explaining something
that I don't even know what it is you
know we all these truths to be
self-evident all men and women are
created equal by the thing you know the
thing God the creator of everything
that's brutal that's actually hard to
watch does this man have the strength
the stamina the mental acuity to take on
what is the toughest job by far in the
world now the answer to me is obviously
no and frankly it's no to anybody with
clear eyes that can see the media once
literally ask those very questions of
Ronald Reagan in 1984 are they gonna ask
the same for Biden no I don't think so
because the mob and the media is
treating Biden like a fragile precious
little artifact New York toilet paper
times actually calling for Biden Mark
Levin has been saying it Russia has been
saying it I
been saying this not the debate
President Trump we all know by the way
who will really be in charge of fighting
wins in November after accomplishing
nothing
remember combined experience Biden
Pelosi Schumer 125 years in the swamp in
DC Trump less than four there now fully
controlled by their radical base
socialists will control the messaging
they won't control the platform they
will control the strategy they will
control the ideas they will try to
literally transform America if we become
that socialist utopia ninety four
trillion new Green Deal fifty-two
trillion Medicare for all guess what
those will all be broken promises and
everything's free and no oil and gas to
produce anything now we see this already
happening in the House of
Representatives the Squad has introduced
a bill to deep on police and by the way
handout reparations in a press
conference yesterday congresswoman Omar
said that her goal was to dismantle the
United States take a look at this we
must recognize that these systems of
oppression are linked as long as our
economy and political systems prioritize
profit without considering who is
profiting who is being shut out we will
perpetuate this inequality so we could
not stop at criminal justice system we
must begin the work of dismantling the
whole system of oppression he's not the
only elected official on the Left openly
calling for America to be destroyed
listen to this scary message from one of
Seattle City Council members take a look
we are coming to dismantle this deeply
oppressive racist sexist violent utterly
bankrupt system of capitalism this
police state we cannot and will not stop
until we overthrow it and replace it
with a world based instead on solidarity
genuine democracy and equality a
socialist world there's no middle ground
in the new radical Democratic Socialist
Party they will destabilize not only
this
country but the entire world along with
it abolishing the police you know the
ones that protect protect grandma
grandpa mom and dad and let's see young
moms that have kids at home maybe they
may be the father's working and then
they'll see control over your property
money your business all in the name of
fairness and redistribution and by the
way to create their perfect utopia the
only problem is everywhere socialism and
whatever form it's been tried has also
failed and don't fall for these empty
promises of everything's free because
there's something called simple basic
fundamental math and maybe Joe could put
aside his abacus and actually get a
calculator out and figure out that let
me be clear
socialism always will end in misery and
despair always and also that will take
away your freedom and the process in the
name of false security